quand on est arrivé au bout du bois de
grunwald on rencontre la frontière le
pont il ne restait plus qu'à faire demi
tour ici on ne passe pas frontière
infranchissable au temps de la guerre
froide
berlin sur une rive potsdam sur l'autre
le bloc de l'est faisait face au bloc de
l'ouest son nom son vrai nom c'est le
pont de glienicke eux mais il restera
dans l'histoire comme le pont des
espions et tout journaliste en reportage
à berlin se devait de le fumer impose
célèbre historiquement et vu dans tous
les films d'espionnage
c'est ici que les deux blocs échangent
leurs prisonniers
comme il ya une dizaine d'années le
pilote américain gary powers gary powers
sans pilote américains son avion espion
a été abattu au-dessus de l'urss en 1960
il sera échangé deux ans plus tard
contre rudolf abel un agent soviétique
va filtrer aux états unis aucune image
de cet échange les agences d'espionnage
et ma discrétion
mais l'histoire deviendra un film sorti
en 2015 et tourné par spielberg sur la
fiche le fameux pont de glienicke en
1985 changement de stratégie les deux
camps décide de faire de la publicité à
les changes qui se prépare un échange de
passes des espions qui se croient sur un
pont entre l'est et l'ouest
ce n'est pas du cinéma c'est arrivé ce
matin à berlin 25 espions occidentaux
emprisonné en allemagne de l'est et en
pologne s'échange contre quatre agents
de l'est incarcéré aux états unis plus
qu'un échange c'est un rituel avec ces
vérifications sa paranoïa un vrai ballet
de barbouze le scénario se déroule comme
prévu arrivé en mercedes des quatre
espions de l'est accompagné de
responsables américains
arrêt au milieu du pont de glee n'est
que tout le monde descend les américains
aussi pour rencontrer côté est les 25
otages qu'ils amènent avec eux en
autobus en 86 encore un échange et les
caméras sont là devant les journalistes
bhl est et l'ouest jouent le jeu de la
détente
et voici que les trois espions de
l'ouest de traverse à leur tour ils
prennent place à bord d'un minibus
l'ouest a relâché cinq espions
nist les américains démentent qu'un
trafic d'argent est appuyé cet échange 9
novembre 89 le mur tombe le lendemain
sur le pont des barrières ont disparu
le pont guennic eux étaient il ya 48
heures encore un des endroits les mieux
gardés de la planète
au vu de ces images une époque qui
semble désormais si lointaine est révolu
la frontière est tombé mais les espions
existe toujours et les échanges aussi il
se déroule maintenant sur un tarmac
anonymes comme ici en 2010 une page
d'histoire est tournée
[Musique]